bonsoir voici donc la dernière des
grandes émissions de cartes sur table
organisé par antenne 2 à l'occasion des
élections présidentielles ce soir
l'invité et monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing pour soi ou participer pour la
première fois un carte sur table
peut-être ne savez-vous pas que la
première question selon notre habitude
est posée par un naturel
monsieur giscard d'estaing quand les
français élisent un président il
souhaite pouvoir cette occasion exprimé
un espoir
alors est-ce qu'on peut exprimer un
espoir quand on est le président sortant
le président qui vient d'exercer son
septennat pendant une période difficile
vous posez la question de savoir c'est
donc toute fonction humaine quelle
qu'elle soit
on peut représenter un espoir quand on
continue d'exercer cette fonction quand
on se représente
mais je ne prenais pas le cas du
président de la république penser à
d'autres fonctions pensez par exemple
aux maires des grandes villes françaises
je pense au cas de marseille ou cas de
bordeaux offert de strasbourg ce sont
des villes qui ont les mêmes mer depuis
souvent plusieurs dizaines d'années et à
chaque élection et se présenter il
représente l'espoir de leur ville
donc je crois que dans la vie nationale
il est parfaitement possible pour
quelqu'un qui a eu à faire face à une
situation difficile ce qui est mon cas
de se présenter à nouveau pour une
action nouvelle
en apportant l'espoir les français sont
un peuple démocratique qui aime bien
décidés et un peuple parfois versatile
est-ce que vous ne croyez pas que 14 ans
ce peut être long à la fois pour les
français et pour vous même c'est
certainement lors on s'est beaucoup
moins long que d'autres fonctions je
rappelle tout à l'heure vous avez des
fonctions qui sont actuellement exercées
en france dans de grandes fonctions
électives pendant des périodes beaucoup
plus longues et en même temps quand vous
regardez le temps qu'il faut pour faire
une heure quelle qu'elle soit vous
apercevez que les oeuvres ça ne
s'accomplit pas en quelques années il
faut souvent pour une vie plusieurs
parfois dizaine d'années pour accomplir
une heure donc l'idée qu' on puisse se
représenter une deuxième fois et
quelques choses qui m'apparaissent
vous les dits naturels j'ai indiqué par
contre que ce serait ma dernière
candidature est donc je suis quelqu'un
qui se présente pour la dernière fois
devant le suffrage de ses compatriotes
et je dirais que ça représente pour moi
quelque chose qui est important est
grave puisque j'étais candidat à de
nombreuses fonctions député maire de ma
ville président de la république c'est
la dernière fois que je me présente
c'est ça facilite les choses
est-ce que ça laisse les mains plus
libres de savoir qu'on ne va pas
demander une réélection ultérieure est
ce qu'on pourra faire plus facilement ce
que l'on veut selon laquelle elle juge
crois qu'il ya un élément qui peut jouer
c'est que lorsque on sait qu'on ne se
représentera pas et lorsque l'opinion
c'est que vous ne vous représenterez
plus il ya des choses qu elle comprendra
d'une manière différente
par exemple j'ai cherché à réaliser une
certaine unité politique vous souvenez
que j'ai écrit aux dirigeants de
l'opposition pour les proposer de me
rencontrer je suis allé dans des villes
ou dans des régions dont les princes et
les élus les plus nombreux étaient des
élus de l'opposition je les fais parce
que je voulais montrer que je recherche
une certaine unité de la france quand je
me représentais je me suis dit qu'on
pouvait croire que je recherchais cette
unité à mon avantage c'est à dire pour
faciliter ma réélection
si au contraire on sait que je me
représente plus je pense que les gestes
que je continuerai bien entendu
d'accomplir pour l'unité de la france
chacun comprendra que nous serons
désintéressée or justement vous avez dit
que vous vouliez pas au fond un
septennat de plus mais certaines un
nouveau alors qu'est-ce qu'il peut y
avoir de nouveau dans un septennat quand
c'est vous qui vous représenter est-ce
que c'est les hommes le climat et
coalition qu'est-ce qui pète il faut se
méfier du mlc la vie moi je vous connais
depuis un certain temps vous ai vu sur
les écrans quelques vaches aussi et est
ce que vous avez décidé d'arrêter
brusquement vos fonctions je peux
observer une telle situation à la même
charge non lieu pas la même charge mais
je fais face à la charge et je croise
dans sa vie à plusieurs reprises on
aperçoit des actions nouvelles qu'il
faut conduire et je prends volontiers
l'exemple de la fusée parce que c'est un
exemple simple que tout le monde peut
comprendre dans la fusillade et étages
et 2,74 à 1981 j'ai eu à faire face à la
crise mondiale
d'ailleurs c'est très curieux parce que
lorsqu'on écoute les commentaires à
l'heure actuelle on a l'air de
vouloir faire oublier aux français ce
que tous les français dans l'avenir
sauront c'est à dire qu'il y à une crise
mondiale
c'est comme si en 1930 1931 les hommes
politiques de l'époque avait fait
campagne en disant me n'y a aucune crise
et imaginer à l'heure actuelle le
jugement qu'on porterait sur leur
discernement donc il a fallu pendant
sept ans qu'avec les français bien
entendu pas du tout tous seuls nous
fassions face à la crise mondiale est
actuellement je pense que par notre
travail collectif
nous avons réuni les conditions qui
permettent de passer à une action plus
offensive et c'est cette action
offensive centre est d'ailleurs sur les
problèmes de la jeunesse et de l'avenir
de la france que je compte proposer pour
le septennat nouveau alors justement
comment est ce que vous pouvez vous y
prendre pour cible et élargir les bases
sociales de votre action que ça vous
savez qu'on présente toujours en france
le combat politique comme s'ils étaient
organisées sur des classes sociales des
catégories sociales vous disiez
l'instant que vous aviez rechercher des
formes d'une idée sociale comment est-ce
qu'on peut élargir
alors j'ai recherché des formes d'unités
jeu direct dans une certaine mesure j'ai
réussi et la preuve c'est que nous
engageons cette élection que la plus
importante de la vie politique française
nous l'engageons dans le calme
il n'ya de violence nulle part à propos
de cette élection c'est très bien qu'il
ya eu des périodes de l'histoire de
france où les grands choix se faisait à
partir d'une atmosphère de violence
deuxième exemple l'année qui vient de
s'achever les années 80 a été l'année où
il y aura eu le moindre le plus petit
nombre de jours de grève en france
depuis 16 ans et donc moins de conflits
sociaux dans d'autres périodes on dirait
c'était dû à la menace du chômage ce
n'est pas exact parce que vous avez une
année où la croissance a été plus faible
c'est 1975 il y avait eu beaucoup plus
de conflits sociaux
et vous avez vu qu'il y a un certain
dialogue entre les dirigeants politiques
de la france mais la vérité sur cette
affaire de dignité de la france c'est
que la division de la france je l' ai
bien vu maintenant elle est en réalité
culturelle elle est idéologique
ce n'est pas seulement d une lutte pour
le pouvoir ou y aurait deux armées qui
manoeuvre sur le terrain c'est que il y
à des idéologies différentes
vous avez des groupes sociaux et
culturels qui ont des attitudes
différentes en france et c'est pourquoi
je pense que l'action pour l'unité qui
sera une
fondamentale de son septennat nouveau
doit avoir un aspect politique mais doit
avoir un aspect culturel je crois que
l'éducation un rôle essentiel à jouer
pour la reconstitution d'une certaine
unité française à mon corps sur ses
divisions sur ces groupes de français
on veut faire croire que dans les
attitudes des groupes sociaux il ya des
candidats qui représente plus
spécialement tel ou tel groupe social
j'ai été frappé par un chiffre à l'heure
actuelle parmi les ouvriers
la catégorie recensés par l'insee comme
les ouvriers
il y a trois candidats qui sont à
égalité et qui sont monsieur marc cher
monsieur mitterrand et moi-même dans les
sondages et plus précis qui sont fait à
l'heure actuelle il apparaît qu'il ya
autant d'ouvriers de membres de la
classe ouvrière qui sont aujourd'hui
décidés à apporter leur bulletin de vote
qu'il n'y en a disposé à voter pour
monsieur marchait aux promotionnaires
donc pas de simplification abusive de la
société française vous pensez qu'on peut
rassembler en ayant si vous êtes élu une
majorité peut-être pas trop importante
après toutes les disputes les chicanes
les divisions qu'on aura entendu pendant
toute cette campagne
ces disputes vont-elles en profondeur je
ne le crois pas je te vois quel écho
vous avez leurs actes place de la
province avec ray comprennent électorale
débute lentement
c'est d'ailleurs naturel parce que comme
elle comme elle avait commencé trop tôt
elle a du mal ensuite à garder ou à
retrouver son souffle mais jusqu'à
présent en province ce n'est pas une
campagne de division des français je
voudrais ce qu est le plus préoccupant
pour moi c'est le scepticisme
j'ai peur que devant la crise devant
l'excès des promesses devant la
multiplication des des suggestions de
toute nature y jette un certain
scepticisme des français est votre
regard y compris à mon égard bien
entendu et c'est pourquoi dans cette
campagne je m'efforcerai de centrer mon
action sur quelques engagements précis
vérifiables
comme je lé fais en 1974 de façon à ce
que les français puissent à la fois
avoir confiance en ce qu'on leur propose
et en même temps pouvoir le moment venu
le vérifier un des reproches que
font vos adversaires quelquefois même
des amis d'ailleurs ce que vous êtes
apparu pendant votre septennat un peu
distant un peu inaccessible pour les
françaises que c'est quelque chose que
vous même vous avez ressenti que non
c'est la fonction passée la fonction et
elle a un un dilemme
vous exercez quand vous êtes président
de la république une double fonction
vous êtes à la tête d'un état qui est
parmi les plus importants du monde avec
une des histoires les plus anciennes du
monde et donc vous avez des obligations
de présence de représentation vous ne
pouvez pas vous y soustraire on ne doit
pas les atténuer je ne crois pas qu'il
soit bon pour la france d'être
représentée à l'extérieur par quelqu'un
qui n'incarne aurait pas la dignité
française et quand vous comparez
l'attitude du président de la république
française tous les chefs d'état c'est un
de ceux dont l'attitude dont le train de
vie est en réalité parmi les plus
modestes
et puis il ya l'autre par l'individu qui
a été élu président la république a été
élu par ses compatriotes et qui
souhaiteraient pouvoir garder avec eux
le contact de plus directe possible et
moi ma règle si je suis réélu s'ils
viennent faire comprendre à l'opinion
qu'il yac'est deux nécessités nécessité
de dignité dans la fonction parce que tu
es une fonction historique où l'on
représente la france est la plus grande
simplicité possible dans les rapports
personnels avec les français et je
souhaite je souhaite que les grands
moyens d'expression me facilite la vie
parce que lorsque vous vivez lorsque
vous vous déplacez entouré de la nuée
des moyens d'expression et d'information
comment voulez vous avoir des rapports
simples avec qui que ce soit
quand vous ne pouvez pas entrer dans une
maison sans être aussitôt sous le feu
des projecteurs vous ne pouvez pas avoir
des rapports simples
donc je souhaiterais que dans mon
septaine à nouveau la fonction conserve
bien entendu sa dignité mais que je
puisse et que l'on me permettent d'avoir
les rapports les plus simples avec les
compacts le comportement du candide
inspirera peut-être un peu celui du
président sans doute aussi maintenant la
rupture entre le parti communiste et le
parti de ces listes en france apparaît
plutôt nettement et l'autre par le
candidat françois mitterrand accepte et
utilise les institutions de la vème
république alors est-ce que le moment
n'est pas venu d'accepter une sorte
d'alternance raisonnable raisonnable
celle dont vous parliez vous même
dans démocratie française mais il faut
il ne faut pas confondre l'alternance ça
n'est pas le fait que l'on dise aux
français malgré votre avis vous allez
changer de majorité
l'alternance est de dire s'il y avait
une autre majorité les françaises et les
français décider de changer d'avis sur
un point important il faut qu'ils
puissent le faire alors je crois qu'à
l'heure actuelle dans la situation de la
france la situation de l'europe
je crois qu'au contraire les français
doivent choisir eux mêmes le maintien la
ligne d'action qui est celle que leur
propose la majorité et donc je suis pour
la possibilité d'une alternance mais je
suis pour le pour le choix par les
français à l'heure actuelle d'une ligne
politique d'un choix de société d'une
organisation de leur vie qui est celle
que leur propose la majorité en suisse
car des stades passons maintenant toute
une série de questions qui touchent aux
problèmes économiques puisque au fond un
point sur lequel les principaux
candidats sont d'accord c'est que le
chômage notamment le chômage des jeunes
mais le chômage est au centre de cette
campagne
il ya d'abord une question qu'on a envie
de vous poser quand vous vous êtes
présenté en 1974 pendant votre campagne
vous vous montriez comme disons plutôt
mieux armés que les autres pour vous
attaquer au problème de l'inflation et
du chômage
or la situation est devenue encore plus
mauvaise que 74 à la suite de la crise
mais les plus mauvaises alors comment
justement vous y prendre pour ne pas
vous heurté au scepticisme comme vous
disiez il ya un instant et bien en
disant une chose tout à fait simple
c'est qu'en matière économique et
sociale
il ne faut pas comparer une situation à
ce que serait une situation parfaite
il faut comparer une situation à ce
qu'aurait été la situation si on avait
fait une autre politique parce qu'il est
très bien de reprocher à l'heure
actuelle de dire il ya entre 1 million
600 mille et un million 700 mille
demandeurs d'emploi en france c'est vrai
c'est beaucoup trop c'est vrai mais il
pourrait y en avoir comme en angleterre
où comme en belgique 10% de la
population active ce qui est le cas dans
les pays d'europe c'est à dire deux
millions et demi et il faudrait savoir
si les politiques qu'on nous propose
n'aurait pas conduit à voir en france
ceux qui viendront d'autres pays 10 % de
déficit budgétaire dans la pib et demi
heure et demi de chômeurs donc il faut
comparer les résultats d'une politique
aux résultats qu'aurait dessus
politique ne l'aï jamais été même si
cette politique ne peut jamais être
appliquée mais là sont appliquées
ailleurs il ya qu à regarder
nous avons des voisins il ya des
politiques diverses qui ont été
appliquées en europe et il y à l'heure
actuelle plusieurs pays d'europe
importants dont le taux de chômage
atteint ou dépasse 10% c'est à dire est
très supérieur au nôtre travail il faut
voir les politiques qu'ils ont appliqué
ils ont appliqué les politiques qu'on
nous propose d'appliquer en france va ce
que j'ai du mal à comprendre c'est que
on cherche à gommer dans l'esprit des
français les quelques données
fondamentales et on se dit si on gomme
ces données ont pour leur faire croire
n'importe quoi il ya une crise et cette
crise nous n'avons ressenti deux fois on
l'a ressenti à 73,74 vers 77 78 les
choses allaient mieux l'eau taux
d'inflation était retombé au dessous de
10% par an c'est pas encore satisfaisant
c'était mieux et l'accroissement du
chômage annuel vous vous en souvenez
vous l'avez vous avez dû le dire était
de l'ordre de 5% par an donc la
situation s'était améliorée
et puis un deuxième choc pétrolier à la
suite des événements d'hier en tout le
monde s'en souvient 80 à 79 80 et à
nouveau nous avons dû faire face
donc on ne peut pas gommer de la réalité
française et internationale le fait il
ya eu deux crises
alors la question est de savoir
avons-nous agi à temps et ma réponse est
oui on peut entrer dans le détail voir
venir et les mesures que nous avons
prises
est elle celle qui convenait à la france
et ma réponse est oui
donc ces mesures ont atténué l'effet de
la crise j'ai dit nous avons fait face
elle n'avait pas le pouvoir
malheureusement d'effacer ou de faire
disparaître des conséquences d'une crise
qui ne dépendait pas de tout de nous
l'ajustement guilloteau mayenne il ya
une question qui vient à l'esprit tout
de suite vous avez présenté samedi
un plan pour réduire le chômage est la
question que je suppose se pose beaucoup
de gens qui vous regardent ce soir c'est
ce plan vous avez dit qu'on pouvait
arriver à créer un million d'emplois
supplémentaires en dehors de ceux qui
seraient créés naturellement par les
collectifs canelas à 10 6 85
eh bien pourquoi pas avant alors c'est
une question tout à fait légitime tout à
fait légitime mais c'est une question
qui est tout à fait fausse parce que
elle part de l'idée que le gouvernement
gouvernement le parlement
moi-même n'aurions rien fait à cet égard
alors je prends les français à témoin
prenons les catégories supplétives la
formation professionnelle
je prends les artisans témoins il y
avait en 1974 lorsque j'ai été élu par
an 70 mille jeunes français qui entrait
en artisanat il en à l'heure actuelle
grâce à l'effort des artisans des
chambres de métiers leurs centres de
formation d'apprentis 135000 il en a
donc cinquante cinq mille de plus que
entre l'apprentissage tous les ans tous
les artisans le savent et ils savent
qu'on a fait voter un texte sur la
réforme de l'apprentissage presle et
maintenant les pactes nationaux
successifs pour l'emploi peut-être que
vous ne les connaissez part peut-être
vous ne connaissez pas mais les français
méconnaissent dans tous les départements
de france il ya eu des délégations qui
ont été constituée il ya eu de
nombreuses réunions et le parlement qui
lui s'en souvient à voter trois lois
juillet 77 juillet 60 18 juillet 80
pacte national pour l'emploi voté par le
parlement
le temps partiel nous proposons en effet
son extension est que nous avons attendu
pour commencer je vous rappelle qu'on a
fait voter au cours de l'automne dernier
un projet de loi permettant précisément
développer le temps partiel en france
les retraites anticipées devra pelle que
c'est un accord entre le patronat et les
syndicats négocier à partir de 1977 qui
vient d'ailleurs d'être renouvelé on a
dit renouveler ce n'était donc pas
nouveau et c'est cet accord qui permet
le départ des travailleurs de certains à
travers participation dernier exemple
les travailleurs immigrés j'ai vu que
quelqu'un proposait à l'heure actuelle
d'arrêter la délivrance de nouvelles
cartes de travail au smic
je vous indique que c'est fait depuis
deux ans donc ce sont des actions qui
ont été commencées il est naturel qu'à
l'occasion d'une campagne nationale
certains grands débats de réflexions des
français on leur dise voilà ce que je
vous propose de faire dans la période
nouvelle à partir de ce qui a été
commencé disiez tout à l'heure
même si giscard d'estaing qu'il y avait
dans l'opinion certain scepticisme alors
est ce que ça veut pas dire que on a
peut-être le sentiment que on a
découvert l'ampleur de ces drames
humains assez tardivement qu'on l'a
considéré comme une sorte de fatalité de
malheur et qu'on a sous-estimé et
l'autre pas est ce que ça veut dire que
c'est une continuité que le plan vise
car pour l'emploi est une continuité
c'est plus exactement le deuxième étage
d'une fusée
enfin je vous rappelle que d'abord quand
on parle de l'emploi il faut jamais
oublier que l'emploi et l'économie ça
marche ensemble et qu'on ne peut pas
parler uniquement de l'emploi comme s'il
n'y avait pas en même temps l'activité
économique
alors la première condition c'est
l'activité économique et pour ça j'ai
indique trois directions où les
décisions étaient prises première
direction l'indépendance énergétique de
la france puisque c'est le fait que nous
soyons victimes des hausses des prix du
pétrole qui nous a mis deux fois dans
ces situations triste il fallait nous en
dégager qui a pris la décision qui l'a
conduit à son terme ce sont bien du
tendon septennat et les deux
gouvernements successifs
vous savez qu'à l'heure actuelle un
tiers de notre électricité est une
électricité nationale et vous savez
peut-être vous l'avez dû le dire que
maintenant l'industrie nucléaire
française qui s'était développée en
partie avec l'aide des techniques
américaines est totalement indépendants
devront signer les accords il ya quinze
jours qui font que maintenant notre
industrie nucléaire est totalement
indépendant deuxième condition avoir des
entreprises compétitives si nos
industries ne sont pas compétitives
elles ne créeront pas d'emplois
il faut donc sur le plan des charges sur
le plan de la liberté des prix qui leur
a été rendu les rendre qu'aux leur
permettre plus exactement d'être
compétitive et la troisième condition
c'est un grand effort de recherche
scientifique et technique
un pays comme le lot doit être à la tête
du progrès scientifique et technique
et là aussi ça n'est pas une promesse en
l'air puisque vous avez que les crédits
de la recherche pour 1981 1 ont été
sensiblement
mentez et que la communauté scientifique
française n'est pas une toute petite
remarque est ce que ce qui a été fait
correspondait à l'ampleur de ce que
représentait le chômage vécu
personnellement pour beaucoup de gens
pouvait-on faire plus oui il faut
toujours se dire une discipline
personnelle qu'on pourrait faire plus
beau toujours vouloir faire plus quand
je compare notre situation actuelle à
celle de nos principaux voisins y
compris nos voisins je dirais mieux
gouvernée par leur porter un jugement
sur les gouvernements voisins mais notre
situation relative à l'heure actuelle
devient une des meilleures d'europe
vous le savez bien nous sommes le seul
pays d'europe seul pays qui va avoir une
croissance économique en 81 tous les
autres allemands compris quand avoir une
baisse de l'activité donc notre
situation nous avons bien fait ce qu'il
fallait je crois pour la préparer alors
justement ça m'amène à l'action que je
voulais vous poser parce que vous dites
on peut maintenant d'ici 1985 créer un
million d'emplois supplémentaires
autrement dit on peut faire mieux au
moment où justement la croissance se
trouve en ce moment
diminuer de façon sensible alors comment
quand on pense comme vous venez de le
dire que la croissance et l'emploi sont
naturellement lié faire mieux au moment
où la croissance va moins bien on le
peut parce que on a préparé les bases et
notamment la question de la formation
professionnelle elle est entièrement
préparé je dirais régler à l'heure
actuelle vous savez quand j'ai été élu
il y avait encore par an 225 milles vers
le français et françaises qui arrivait à
la recherche d'un emploi sans formation
professionnelle 225 et qui donc avait
très peu de chances de trouver un emploi
stable et rémunérateur sans formation
professionnelle on à ramener ce chiffre
à l'heure actuelle à 95 milles et le
gouvernement a préparé un plan de
formation professionnelle qu'il entre en
vigueur à partir de l'automne prochain
et qui va réduire ce chiffre à 0
c'est à dire que tout jeune français
tout jeune française aura une formation
professionnelle en arrivant sur le
marché du travail
combien de temps mais le ceci est
réalisé à partir de l'automne pour
définir pour qu'on arrive à zéro il faut
combien des travaux sera à zéro en 1985
on va réduire par paliers de 95
actuel à 0 et l'objectif c'est donc que
tout jeune français tout jeune française
est le choix entre un emploi et une
formation professionnelle vous savez
qu'il ya une idée mais les français ont
très souvent qui est de dire il vaudrait
mieux remplacer l'aide au chômage parues
une aide ou travaillent à une création
d'emplois bien dans le cas de la
jeunesse
le problème c'est tout à fait simple
parce que au lieu d'avoir un jeune
chômeur et des il vaut bien mieux avoir
un jeune en formation puisque de toute
façon on accroît sa capacité personnelle
et sa capacité à travailler pour la
france en poursuivant on améliore encore
sa formation donc tout jeune devra avoir
un emploi ou une formation penser que en
dépit de la situation internationale et
de l'économie française difficiles
pouvaient tenir en vous engageant
personnellement ce pari de la même façon
que vous avez réglé par exemple
l'augmentation depuis 74 due à des
revenus des personnes âgées
oui le fait on peut le faire seulement
je voudrais ou bien dire les choses
simplement en 1974 avait pris deux
engagements parmi d'autres mais des
engagements très précis et je voudrais
que les françaises et les français qui
actuellement sont submergés de
publication tous genres spa pour leur
expliquer que je n'ai pas tenu mes
engagements faudrait simplement qu'ils
qui se souviennent de ceux ci j'avais
indiqués comme engagement centrale de
marc campagne l'amélioration du sort des
personnes âgées
je reviens pas sur les motifs c'était
une obligation de justice vis-à-vis des
personnes âgées et la france avait à cet
égard en retard inadmissible vis à vis
des autres pays et retard j'avais
ressenti en voyant nos voisins qui
avaient réglé depuis longtemps le
problème de leurs personnes âgées
nous avons donc que pris cet engagement
il a été tenu d'ailleurs personne ne dit
le contraire
personne ne dit le contraire et ça porte
sur des millions de personnes j'ai fait
le chiffrage de ce que ça a coûté si on
avait conservé la situation des
personnes âgées en france telle qu'elle
était en 74 c'est à dire si leur
prestation leur retraite avait
simplement accompagné la hausse des prix
par rapport ce que nous avons fait en
plus c'est à dire lors amélioration a
représenté pour le septennat une dépense
de 50
yar de francs 50 milliards de francs et
pour l'année 1980 une dépense de 12
milliards de francs or les propositions
je fais pour l'emploi je ne sais pas si
vous me demanderez tout à l'heure si on
veut continuer d'être un peu sur les
détails vous verrez que l'ordre de
grandeur est inférieur à ce que nous
avons fait collectivement les
enregistrements qu'elle est tellement
dans le 1er septembre et nous avons
accompli deux autres actions qui étaient
également des actions de dépenses qu'il
fallait accomplir
l'une en faveur des handicapés et la
dépense totale sur le septennat la
dépense supplémentaire a été de 24
milliards de francs et 8 milliards de
francs supplémentaires en 1981 et pour
les familles où la dépense était du même
ordre de grandeur 23 milliards de francs
pendant le septennat de plus que la
hausse des prix donc vous voyez que nous
avons pu faire venir les français ont pu
faire pour les personnes âgées les
familles les handicapés un effort de
rétablissement de situations qu'ils
peuvent faire à l'heure actuelle pour
les personnes qui sont à leur chargement
en revenant justement mesure que vous
proposez on a parlé de la formation
professionnelle pour les jeunes mans il
ya une autre mesure alors c'est très
important c'est la première mesure c'est
la plus importante tout jeune français
tout jeune français aura soit un emploi
soit la poursuite d'une formation
professionnelle et ceci et programmés et
financés
c'est à dire que dans la préparation des
prochains budgets il ya les ressources
correspondantes déjà inscrits donc il
n'y a pas de dépenses supplémentaires à
cet égard toute façon on reviendra à la
fin mais quand on aura bien compris les
mesures on reviendra au problème du
chiffrage qui à ma connaissance n'a pas
encore été donnée donc on vous demandera
ce chiffre à rien une autre mesure dont
vous parlez qui elle touche à la
réduction du nombre de travailleurs
immigrés en france alors vous expliquer
dans votre plan expliqué que l on peut
accroître les incitations financières
pour payer des départs volontaires de
travailleurs immigrés à la question
quand voudrais vous poser c'est qu'elle
est le genre de
victime de départ au fond est ce que ça
sera significatif si oui quand et
combien de gens disent que ça touchera
donc combien ce que d'emplois ça
libérera pour des travailleurs français
très bien là il faut quelques chiffres
de passer d'une question délicate celle
des travailleurs immigrés et d'ailleurs
les français qui sont qu'ils sont
généreux et qui ne veulent pas qu'ils
aient de discrimination veulent que ce
sujet soit traité avec avec attention et
que l'on sache exactement ce que l'oms
les travailleurs immigrés il en a à
l'heure actuelle en france un million et
demi
sur ce million et demi vous avez des
travailleurs qui viennent communauté
européenne pas notamment des italiens
qui sont venus en france ont gardé leur
nationalité ils ne sont pas concernés
bien entendu par ce problème
il ya des travailleurs qui viennent de
pays candidat à l'adhésion
principalement les portugais et les
espagnols
et là aussi comme ils sont candidats à
l'adhésion ils seront traités comme les
membres de la communauté européenne
ils ne sont pas concernées par sopron en
dehors de ces travailleurs il en reste
900 milles et sur ses neuf cent mille
vous en avez 700 milles qui sont des
personnes isolées étrangères c'est à
dire des personnes qui sont venues
chercher du travail en france qui sont
isolées c'est à dire qu'ils ne sont pas
avec leur famille dans leur milieu
familial et qui retourne périodiquement
dans leur pays ce sont ceux là qui sont
concernés par la possibilité du retour
mais toi moi c'est les autres veulent
repartir aussi en faciliterait le retour
mais ceux qui sont directement concernés
sont ceux qui sont en dehors de leur
milieu familial qui sont venus chercher
du travail dans un pays qui sait qu'il
ne pourra pas leur offrir durablement du
travail alors nous avons un système des
deux au chômage pour les français que je
connais bien puisque nous sommes à
l'origine de ce système qui a été créée
vous en souvenez en 74 et c'est un
système qui a pour objet de permettre
aux français d'attendre de retrouver un
travail et n'est pas raisonnable
d'appliquer ce système à des
travailleurs qui retourneront un jour
dans leur pays et qu'ils sont en france
dans la tente d'un travail que nous
pourrons plus leur fournir
puisque nous savons dans les années
prochaines avec l'autre millions 600
mille demandeurs d'emploi et avec nos
jeunes qui arrivent nous ne pourrons
plus leur offrir de nouveau travail il
faut donc réadapter notre système dead
pour respecter leurs droits sociaux mais
pour les invités
utiliser ses droits sociaux en vue de
leur retour chez eux et de la recherche
d'un travail dans leur propre pays quel
ordre de grands sacs ont bien qu'elle a
mon avis sur les la période que je
couvre selle à 80 85
nous devons viser un ordre de grandeur
de 250000 et les études que nous avons
faites nous permettent de penser que
c'est un chiffre près à liestal et donc
pas le départ de tous les travailleurs
immigrés c'est le départ de d'environ
250 mille d'entre eux s'ils ne veulent
pas partir et un problème d'un site
erreur dans la citation par le soul et
en réglant les incitations l'expérience
a montré puisqu'à l'heure actuelle nous
avons déjà des départs que l'on pouvait
accélérer le rythme de ces départs et la
formule que je proposerai c'est d'abord
en effet d'améliorer les conditions
financières de leur départ c'est bien
que certaines critiques mais il faut
voir que s'il reste dans notre système
des de chômage à dépenses totales est
également considérable mais de chercher
à le faire des entreprises sous forme
contractuelle
c'est à dire que telle ou telle branche
de la mécanique du bâtiment ou de tel
autre passe un contrat avec l'état dans
lequel l'état aidera les entreprises à
faciliter donc prendre en charge le
retour de certains travailleurs immigrés
en contrepartie d'un engagement de
recrutement d'un nombre de travailleurs
français équivalent qu'elle appelle le
contrat retour recrutement alors il ya
une autre mesure parce que ce sont des
choses qui intéressent les gens qui sont
concrètes et précises et une autre
mesure dont vous avez parlé qu'ils aient
la possibilité d'avancer l'âge de la
préretraite de l'abaisser de par exemple
60 ans à 58 ans et puis d'inciter un
certain nombre de fonctionnaires à
prendre leur retraite plus tôt tout en
ayant leur pension à taux plein alors
qu'elle un parc est ce que ça peut avoir
et est ce que c'est parce que c'est
aussi une question que se posent les
gens est ce que au fond faisant de
mesure ça n'est pas souvent le genre de
mesure que la gauche proposée depuis un
certain temps et auxquelles les membres
de la majorité quelques fois les plus
éminents entre répondait en disant ah
bah c'est pas possible ou bien c'est un
peu la démagogie
non c'est différent il y a eu un certain
moment des revendications collectives
sur l'abaissement de l'âge obligatoire
de la retraite vous souvenez qu'on
souhaitait que cette tâche soit abaissée
obligatoire ce qui a été fait est
différent ça a été de créer des droits
pour les catégories
vous savez que l'âge de droit commun de
la retraite en france et 65 ans dans
notre régime général maire on peut la
prendre à 60 ans dans certaines
conditions les femmes les travailleurs
de certains métiers pénibles les anciens
combattants et prisonniers
bref certaines catégories déterminées
alors on a créé une possibilité de pré
retraites à l'heure actuelle dans
laquelle les personnes qui prennent leur
pré retraite conservent 70 % de leur
salaire brut
c'est à dire en fait une proportion
supérieure de leur salaire d'activité en
attendant de toucher leur retraite
définitive ce que je propose c'est qu'on
abaisse large large est actuellement de
60 ans à 59 ou 58 ans et il y a là des
travailleurs à ses nombreux puisque au
delà de 60 ans déjà des travailleurs je
le disais les femmes les travailleurs
des métiers pénibles les anciens
combattants peuvent prendre leur
retraite jusqu'à 60 ans personne ne peut
la prendre
donc si on abaisse 5,60 à 59-58 il y à
des tranches nombreuses qui peuvent si
elles le souhaitent bien entendu
bénéficier de cette pré retraite
alors quel est le l'avantagent cette
solution c'est que c'est une solution
qui est constamment adaptable on peut le
faire pour deux ans on peut le faire
pour trois ans on peut le faire pour un
an
d'autre part ces jeux la base du
volontariat c'est à dire ceux qui
voudront bénéficier de ce système le
courant il n'y aura pas d'obligation et
nous avons calculé qu'il y aura fait une
possibilité
à cet égard d'environ cent mille
volontaires dans la tranche 58 à 60 ans
et cent mille volontaires dans la
tranche de 60 à 65 ans si on leur
facilite leur départ par quelques
dispositions particules toujours horizon
85 voilà alors pour les fonctionnaires à
l'heure actuelle il n'y a pas de système
de pré retraite et il se proposerait au
gouvernement bien entendu et c'est le
parlement qui devra voter une loi que
l'on créé un système de pré retraite
pour les fonctionnaires pouvant partir
deux ans avant l'âge normal de la
retraite et avec des recrutements
équivalent de jeunes fonctionne et nous
surprend jantes en 20 questions parce
qu'il y en a cinquante mille allons donc
la moitié bénéficierait de ce système
est ce que ça fait pas partie des
et que proposer des formations de gauche
et quand elle est proposée à ce moment
là la majorité et le gouvernement leur
répondait c'est démagogique
donc je crois que ceci a toujours devant
c'est ça fait l'objet de discussions
contractuelles la retraite anticipée ça
n'est pas le gouvernement qui l'a
proposé des négociations entre le
patronat et les syndicats pour les
fonctionnaires et pour les
fonctionnaires ça n'a pas été proposée
jusqu'ici je ne connais pas de projet de
loi je ne crois pas proposé cette mesure
en tout cas si la majorité
si l'opposition veut s'associer au vote
des dispositions tant mieux j'ai dit que
je pensais qu'il devait y avoir une
approche non partisane du problème de
l'emploi
je crois que c'est un problème national
puisque les uns les autres vins dit que
leurs solutions sont convergentes et
bien dans ce cas là pourquoi ne pas
voter les mesures que nous proposerons
allongé un calendrier tout à fait précis
alors que jeunes optent dans les autres
programmes tout est vague
l'échéance les dates les chiffres nous y
reviendrons bon le calendrier serait le
suivant négociation patronat-syndicats
aboutissant avant l'été sur le problème
de la durée et de l'aménagement du temps
de travail la qualité en suivant temps
c'est une autre question différente ça
et d'autre part dépôt immédiat du projet
de loi permettant la pré retraites dans
le secteur public où il a vu que nos
secteurs publics
c'est une possibilité qui s'est ouverte
aux fonctionnaires qui seraient
remplacés en nombre équivalent parce
qu'à mon avis à deux formules qu'on peut
pas retenir l'une j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure c'est le recrutement
systématique de fonctionnaires faisant
peser une charge nouvelle sur l'économie
française et l'autre serait de ne pas
remplacer les fonctionnaires partant à
l'heure actuelle dans la situation de
l'économie française ce serait bien
entendu aggraver le problème de l'emploi
donc une précision vous dites
abaissement temporaire à 50,80 en
province a dit c'est une durée de
combien de ces états ça doit être
discutée entre le patronat et les
syndicats à mon avis c'est un devoir
mais disons deux ans ça peut être
d'accord sur la pré retraite est un
accord d'un an renouvelable
alors on peut imaginer un accord sur
deux ans maintenant une période de deux
ans alors justement les dilutions les
discussions sur la réduction de la durée
annuelle du travail alors ce sont des
discussions qui sont entre représentants
des employeurs côté ça je crois que
c'est des choses que les gens
montpellier qui les intéresse parce que
après tout c'est leur vie quotidienne
que ça concerne tout à fait directement
au fond c'est un projet qui existait
déjà la réduction de la durée annuelle
du travail qui se dispute entre les
employeurs et les salariés
vous dites il faudrait que ce soit fait
avant l'été et par quel miracle qu'est
ce que ça serait fait avant l'été alors
que jusqu'à présent ça ne s'est pas fait
parce que c'était sur le point d'être
fait c'était sur le point d'être faits
la vérité c'est que la venue de
l'échéance présidentielle a conduit les
partenaires sociaux à reporter
finalement la conclusion de leur accord
je ne dis pas qu'ils étaient tout à fait
d'accord sur tout il y avait des
différences encore important qu'il
savait sur certains points mais deux
fois ils ont été près de conclure je
suis convaincu pour ma part que s'ils
reprennent cette discussion avec la
volonté d'aboutir et un gouvernement les
habitants ardemment aboutir au cours du
printemps open je suis convaincu qu'on
ne saurait à l'esprit qu'ils aboutiront
à un accord alors sur la sphère de la
durée du travail
oui il faut dire des choses sérieuses au
dire des choses terribles et comme vous
le savez il ya des propositions pour
dire on va ramener la durée du travail à
voilà c'est un des thèmes principaux la
campagne vous ne crois pas que les
français réfléchissent davantage quand
on fait cette proposition on passe à
côté du problème car la question est de
savoir quel est le salaire qui sera
touché par quelqu'un qui travaillera 35
heures est ce que c'est un salaire de 35
heures est ce que c'est un salaire de 40
heures si on veut que ce soit un partage
du temps de travail
il faut que ce soit un salaire de 35
heures et si l'on veut au contraire
maintenir le pouvoir d'achat il faut
soit un salaire de 40
je suis convaincu pour ma part que les
français dans leur majorité ne souhaite
pas et d'ailleurs n'accepterons pas une
réduction de leur pouvoir d'achat
pas encore mais ce qui peut y avoir une
évolution au jeu le raccompagne de leur
proposera non je crois franchement que
nous sommes un pays où il ya encore des
besoins de niveau de vie important
notamment dans le monde du travail
notamment dans le monde des travailleurs
manuels et je ne crois pas qu'il soit
réaliste de leur proposer un schéma dans
lequel leur niveau de vie baisserait or
je note que dans le programme des
programmes des autres candidats
lorsqu'on parle de 35 heures on ne dit
rien sur le niveau de rémunération alors
que c'est la seule question
la question centrale c'est à quel niveau
si si si si on dit quand même quelque
chose parce que certains visent par
exemple qu'il faut que ce soit avec
maintien justement du salaire
correspondant à 40 heures par exemple ma
connaissance c'est ce que dit georges
marchais et d'autres par exemple c'est
ce que nous avait dit toujours à cette
émission françois mitterrand d'autres
disent que c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut examiner progressivement et
peut-être d'ailleurs en coordination
avec nos partenaires européens examinés
il faut dire les choses clairement est
celui négocié les négocier
mais négocier photo indiqué quel est
l'objectif que l'on poursuit
vous avez créé travaux qui ont été menés
au plan m nos partenaires européens
montrent qu'il n'y a défait de création
d'emplois nous parlons là de la lutte
contre le chômage que s'il y a une
certaine réduction de la rémunération
accompagnant la réduction du nombre
d'heures or je crois je vous répète que
ce n'est pas réaliste et donc je suis
pour une autre formule qui est de faire
que dans la durée
la réduction naturelle du temps de
travail qui continuera à se produire en
france soit considérée comme une des
satisfactions enregistré par le monde du
travail
alternativement à une augmentation des
rémunérations et que ce soit par cette
réduction négociés branche par branche
on arrive un partage progressif du
travail et c'est pourquoi je souhaite
que d'une part la négociation qui
aboutissent et ensuite dans le cadre de
cette négociation des négociations
branche par branche pour examiner
l'échelonnement possible de cette
réduction de la durée du travail
pourquoi faut-il une une négociation
d'ensemble c'est parce que s'il ya
réduction de la durée du travail sans en
même temps souplesse des horaires de
travail
il ya une baisse de productivité de
l'outil industriel français il faut donc
en même temps un assouplissement des
règles de la durée du travail et c'est
pourquoi la négociation est nécessaire
donc il y a là une formule qui ne peut
pas procuré un grand nombre d'emplois
tout de suite mais qui sur la période
peut procurer un nombre important
d'emplois si vous êtes le décale façon
vous pensez que vous allez améliorer le
climat social en france ce qu'il y a
si vous y croyez un état de grâce tout
de suite après l'élection
non je ne vole tout cette expression de
jeudi quelque part l'état de grâce est
une expression de théologie je vois
d'ailleurs qu'à l'heure actuelle tout le
monde se rallie à la théologie
catholique orthodoxe morize oui
naturellement
enfin je vois pas ce genre de conversion
il n'y a pas d'état de grâce d'autant
plus que certains syndicats et notamment
la cgt ne vont pas mystère de leurs
intentions au contraire d'obtenir par
des moyens de pression un certain nombre
de satisfactions sociale mais j'ai noté
les réactions des cantons organisations
syndicales à mon plan pour l'emploi
et ce sont des réactions au total modéré
et réaliste c'est à dire qu'elle porte
un certain nombre de jugements sur
certaines dispositions et joue avec je
suis convaincu qu'on peut aboutir un
accord négocié sur l'aménagement de la
durée du travail au printemps de canard
à l'enregistrer redécouvrez le rôle des
syndicats
j'ai jamais cessé de le découvrir mais
quelques habache rappelez vous que cette
négociation sur la durée du travail
elle a été lancée à partir d'un rapport
que nous avons fait établir par monsieur
giraud des landes successives de la ratp
divers france et je vous rappelle que
j'avais l'année dernière demandé à ce
que cette négociation reprenne en
souhaitant que parlement puisse
sanctionner par la loi sa conclusion
positive il ya eu un retard mais la
méthode a toutefois été la même alors
justement les les réactions de vos
adversaires à votre planque et le par
l'adversité les concurrents si vous
voulez me disant ce devant concurrents
qui se considère comme vos adversaires
et bien leur action était au fond de
faire deux sortes de critiques l'une de
dire on va tous à un manque
d'imagination et n'a pas l'ampleur
suffisante pour répondre à la difficulté
de la situation et l'autre grande
critique faux quotidienne c'est mais
tout ça n'est pas chiffré
je souhaiterais que tous les français
prennent le temps de lire le programme
que j'ai présenté mon plan pour l'emploi
et les autres plans qui ont été
présentés sous votre équipe puisse un
choix reposer sur la table les
différents plans et tout ce qu'ils
feront vrombir on que d'un côté il est
une réflexion systématique portant sur
l'ensemble du problème est que le reste
est extraordinairement osa
extraordinairement vague est accompagné
de rares évaluation chiffrée
et alors
exact vous donner un exemple
le seul chiffre qui soit cité dans le
plan du candidat socialiste chiffre qui
est de dire il faut créer cent cinquante
mille emplois de fonctionnaires et
auquel on ajouterait 60 il emploie pour
des organisations associations faisant
descendre utilité locales collectivités
intelligente des milles alors ça fait
deux cent dix villes je vois que vous
savez faire une addition c'est ça dont
je vois si vous savez faire une
multiplication par ce que le candidat
ensuite elles seules chiffres qu'il cite
pas le seul si tous mes projets bien va
falloir qu'il y avait là des missions
les fermes à qui il dit ensuite cela
coûterait 12 milliards de francs
on va faire le calcul j'ai un rayon mais
fournit d'ailleurs il n'est pas
nationale mais ce n'est pas mon fait
ça peut être bien alors regardez on en
est quand 150 mille fonctionnaires
quel est le coût actuel dans les
évaluations du budget pour 1982 du
fonctionnaire du traitement moyen du
fonctionnaire de la fonction publique
c'est 100 livres c'est exactement 98
mille cinq cent dix ans en 1950 milko
multiplient sans ménage
ça fait beaucoup de zéros et cela fait
comme vous le voyez 15 milliards de
francs
donc la première moitié de la mesure
fait déjà 15 milliards il reste les
60000 qui ne pourront pas de payer par
les associations les collectivités c'est
l'état qui les paiera qui les mettra à
la disposition des associations 60000 le
traitement moyen d'un agent de ces
catégories en france représente charges
sociales comprises 80 mille francs par
an fall calcul hoon c dont 60 milko
multiplient 90
et bien cela fait 4 milliards week vous
faites le total des deux
cela fait 19 milliards 8
c'est à dire pratiquement 20 milliards
autrement dit le seul chiffre qui est
cité dans le programme est un chiffre
qui est faux de plus de 50% ses 19
milliards 8
alors qu'on le dit ça coûterait 12
milliards et pour vous montrer combien
ces mesures sont mal choisis supposer
qu'on crée en france 150 mille
fonctionnaires plus 60 milles c'est à
dire de 110000 il faudra les payer
pendant 35 ans donc ce sera 10 9
milliards par an pendant une période de
temps fort longue
d'autre part on arrêtera ensuite tout
recrutement ce sera le phénomène bien
connu pendant laquelle on recrute
d'abord 210 mille personnes ensuite on
s'arrête donc les générations à venir
verront leur avenir bouché par cette
situation de recrutement mais surtout
une pré retraite en france combien ce
que ça coûte beaucoup de 50 mille francs
par an
donc ça coûte la moitié de la création
d'un emploi de fonctionnaire
une pré retraite ça secret pendant
combien dans deux ans trois ans donc
avec la moitié de ces crédits la moitié
de ces crédits on peut en réalité créé
deux fois plus d'emplois et en ayant
trait à supporter la charge que pendant
deux ans ou trois ans alors que coûte
mon programme
oui parce que au fond ce je vous ai
demandé ce que coûtent entre nous mais
plutôt une après midi n'a préféré me
dire ce que parce que j'ai vu un seul
chiffre
il est faux et c'est un chiffre
parfaitement vérifiables traitement de
150 mille fonctionnaires on le connaît
on connaît les organisations syndicales
le connaissent soixante mille agents de
collectivités
on connaît le plus donc ces 20 milliards
au lieu de 12 milliards alors le coot du
programme
il faut voir d'abord qu'à des mesures
déjà financés dont je ne reprends pas la
formation professionnelle c'est dans le
budget il ya d'autre part des mesures
qui ne comporte pas dépenses
supplémentaires par exemple si on aide
les entreprises à recruter des chômeurs
en payant une partie de leur salaire et
qu'on prélève cela sur l'aide au chômage
elle même
il ya simplement transfert de dépenses
il n'y a pas de dépenses nouvelles
alors le coude des mesures que j'ai
énuméré pour l'année 1980 puisqu'elle
est déjà engagé serait relativement
limité le temps de mettre en place les
dispositifs c'est de l'ordre de 2
milliards de francs pour l'année 1982
c'est de l'ordre de 7 milliards 200
millions de francs et pour l'année 1983
c'est de l'ordre de 10 milliards 700
millions de francs au delà vous vous
direz que c'est déraisonnable présenter
des calculs puisque sa dépendent
beaucoup d'évolutions qu'il est
difficile de calculer à 3 ans d'échéance
donc disons 2 milliards 7 milliards 10
milliards 7
deux jours après tout à l'heure que
l'augmentation supplémentaire des
dépenses budgétaires que nous avons logé
dans l' équilibre budgétaire pour les
personnes âgées ces 12 milliards en 1981
donc la montre qu'un effort de la
collectivité de même nature peut
permettre de faire face à ces chats et
enfin aux ménages mais parce qu'il ya un
aspect qu'on a oublié ses dires de notre
faute c'est ce qui touche au travail
partiel alors là aussi n'est ce pas
dedans le le programme de celui vous
avez mon adversaire et que j'appellerai
mon concurrent
il est frappant de voir que mon travail
partiel n'ait pas prononcé
c est le mot immigré n'est pas prononcé
or ces deux points sur lesquels une
action qu'on peut naturellement
concevoir d'une manière ou d'une autre
est évidemment indispensable
aucun ces monnaies prononcé travail
partiel c'est probablement une des
mesures qui peut créer le plus grand
nombre d'emplois et répondre au plus
grand nombre de situations il faut
d'abord être tout à fait clair travail
partiel ça ne veut pas dire coupez les
les emplois existants pour les
transformer en un plus grand nombre
d'emplois partiels c'est de créer de
nouveaux emplois à temps partiel par
exemple dans les demandeurs d'emploi
l'heure actuelle vous en avez donc entre
1 million 600 mille et un million 700
mille et vous avez de nombreuses femmes
et de nombreux jeunes et toutes les
enquêtes montrent que beaucoup de ces
femmes et que beaucoup de ces jeunes
préféreraient débuté par un emploi à
temps partiel
or à l'heure actuelle nous ne ferons pas
d'emplois à temps partiel
il a fallu faire voter une loi cela a
été fait il faut maintenant organiser
ces emplois à temps partiel et cette
offre d'emploi et nous prévoyons dans
notre mont blanc d'aider les entreprises
à proposer de tels emplois faut bien
comprendre que la création d'emplois
nouveaux qui seront des emplois à temps
partiel donc plus nombreux qu en serait
la création d'emplois de type
conventionnel et nous fait confiance à
l'économie française pour créer des
emplois des 10,6 à 85 alors l'économie
française a toujours créé des emplois
dans la période récente
vous savez qu'elle a créée aux alentours
le chiffon peu aux alentours de cinq à
sept cent mille emplois supplémentaires
salariés par contre elle a perdu un
certain nombre d'emplois notamment dans
l'agriculture et au total il reste un
solde positif de l'ordre de 500 mille
créations d'emplois et je pense que
l'économie française va continuer à
créer des emplois mais ça suppose un
appui naturellement des pouvoirs publics
la recherche d'un niveau d'activité
élevé
bien entendu des encouragements des
activités dans certains secteurs
créateurs d'emplois
pas d'enjeu bull dire les économies
d'énergie dans le bâtiment que j'ai
citées dans mon plan c'est une activité
où tout le monde gagne puisque on fait
des économies d'énergie ont fait
travailler les entreprises du bâtiment
ont créé des emplois
et puis il ya toutes les technologies du
futur qui vont se développer dans les
années prochaines
et qui sont déjà créatrice d'emplois
avec le nucléaire aura créé en france
plus de cent mille emplois vous savez
que l'électronique à l'heure actuelle
crée des emplois en france donc nous
avons des industries créatrices
d'emplois quand on vous écoute et une
question qu'on a envie de vous poser
d'ailleurs vous la posez là on va vous
l'imposé condamné hier également envie
de poser à vos concurrents kavudi c'est
quand vous lisez les plans des autres de
lutte contre le chômage le plan de ce
marché chirac ou de monsieur mitterrand
vous n'y trouvez jamais une mesure dont
vous vous dites tiens est intéressante
au fond je pourrais très bien intégré ce
que je voudrais vous vous trompez vous
trompez par exemple je suis convaincu je
partage le sentiment que monsieur chirac
il faut freiner l'augmentation des
charges qui pèsent sur l'économie
française ça a été toujours pour moi une
préoccupation dans le programme de
benoît qui a précédé voulant truquer les
élections 1978 j'avais demandé qu'on
mette le plafonnement des charges qui
pèsent sur les entreprises
franck nous ne pouvons pas supporter la
la concurrence des autres 2
ainsi les charges qui pèsent sur notre
économie continue à augmenter et donc
c'est au contraire favorable au
plafonnement et si nous pouvons à la
réduction de ses charges
d'autre part vous me dites que de
monsieur mitterrand est favorable mais
ton à une négociation concertée sur la
réduction de la durée du travail si tel
est le cas je m'en réjouis
ne croyez pas ça je suis convaincu au
contraire que nous devons chercher les
sous et musulmans raisonnables partout à
10 ans d'un problème tellement grave est
comme chez lui et j'ai les jambes de
nogaro et je souhaite collaborent de
façon non partisane
si je suis président je proposerai trois
sujets pour une politique non partisane
c'est à dire une politique conduite par
des méthodes qui évitent ou qui
réduisent l'affrontement des parties ce
sera la défense parce que nous vivons
dans une période tellement dangereuses
qu'il faudrait que la défense nationale
de la france soit soutenu par l'ensemble
des partis politiques ce qui n'est pas
encore à l'heure actuelle le camp ce
devrait être la politique étrangère j'ai
souvent proposé des consultations sur
les coraux suggère dans les grands
moments de politique étrangère il y en a
d'ailleurs eu quelques-unes et à mon
avis ça devrait être l'emploi j'estime
sur ces trois sujets défense politique
étrangère emploi nous devrions
rechercher des attitudes non particules
ont pensé si vous êtes élu vous aurez
plus de chance que les années
précédentes
on sait ce qu'ils volaient et je
tâcherai d'amplifier les résultats que
nous avons en ce moment les réparer des
agriculteurs les agriculteurs demandent
que l'on garantisse leur revenu il ya
une négociation actuelle du marché
commun bruxelles alors est-ce que vous
pouvez vous engager ce soir c'est
giscard d'estaing à ce que en 1981 les
agriculteurs français puissent
garantie avoir garanti leur pouvoir
d'achat ce n'est pas tout à fait ce
qu'ils demandent pas les agriculteurs
français sont à l'heure actuelle
préoccupé et souvent mécontents et ils
le sont bien qu'on est garantie en 1981
le revenu l'agriculture pourquoi le sont
ils c'est parce que les charges qui
supportent ont augmenté en 1979 1981
tous années 80 beaucoup plus vite que
les prix qu'il touche qui s'agitait
carburant bien entendu mais qu'il
s'agisse aussi des engrais qu'il
s'agisse des matériels qu'ils achètent
et ils ont donc vu ses secrets pour une
situation ce qu'ils achetaient leur
coûtaient plus en plus cher et où ce
qu'ils vendaient se vendait un peu plus
cher mais pas du tout dans la même
proportion pour 1981 qu'est ce que nous
avons fait qui a été de leur garantir
leurs revenus
et puis avec la collectivité nationale
s'était pas du tout une aumône n'était
pas ça c'était un geste de solidarité a
considéré que comme vis-à-vis d'autres
catégories comme par exemple la
sidérurgie ou comme les mines de charbon
pour lesquelles la collectivité supporte
des charges
il fallait garantir le revenu des
agriculteurs et leurs dirigeants ont
reconnu avec beaucoup de d'honnêteté que
la province avait été tenue donc on a
maintenu leur but les agriculteurs en 80
quand on a tjrs un revenu global
il ya des situations particulières et
donc certainement telle ou telle
catégorie
je pense en particulier aux éleveurs se
sont trouvés se trouvent encore en
difficulté malgré cette garantie de
revenus à l'heure actuelle qu'est ce que
nous cherchons et qu'est ce qu'il
demande c'est de pouvoir assurer leur
existence à partir du prix des produits
qu'ils vendent
et donc là la place politique que nous
venons à l'heure actuelle des bacs est
en cours à bruxelles c'est d'obtenir des
prix rémunérateurs pour nos agriculteurs
en 1980 un essai la directive qui a été
donné formellement à notre ministre de
l'agriculture j'avais tout à l'heure des
au téléphone chancelier ce but je lui en
veux dit que c'était pour nous une
question fondamentale
alors à partir de ces prix quelle doit
être la nature de la garantie à donner
aux agriculteurs français pour la
campagne 80
je crois qu autant discuter avec leurs
dirigeants ce qui n'a pas eu jusqu'ici
et je crois que ceux qui le souhaitent
plutôt c'est qu'on leur dit
ce que les prix de vente de leurs
produits évolueront en 1981 au moins
aussi vite que les prix d'achat des
produits qu'ils achètent et on peut le
faire par les prix en provenance de
bruxelles
on peut le faire par des techniques
intérieur notamment en utilisant la
fiscalité c'est à dire la tva comme on
l'a fait dans telle ou telle
circonstance avant qu'on fera face au
point une phase importante pas que les
peuples épris de skill board évolué
cette année comme les prix au moins
qu'au mépris de ce qu'ils achètent
oui avant qu'on ne passe aux problèmes
de politique étrangère parce qu'on a un
stand de questions à vous poser sur ce
sujet il ya tout de même quelque chose
de frappant c'est que vous avez écrit
dans un style démocratie française qu'il
y avait un groupe central en france vous
vous intéressiez dans ce livre aux
employés ou cadres moyens burnes un peu
l'impression que cette catégorie qui est
à ma connaissance la catégorie dont les
effectifs s'accroissent le plus
aujourd'hui dans l'économie des employés
les cadres moyens est à peu près absente
du débat on parle beaucoup des ouvriers
c'est très bien des personnes âgées des
femmes seules par les agriculteurs
et puis personne enfin on se sent ne
parle pas beaucoup des problèmes d un
[ __ ] cannes moyens or ils sont de plus
en plus nombreux et ils sont touchés eux
aussi par des problèmes de chômage
votre remarque est tout à fait juste et
je trouve que dans cette campagne
jusqu'à présent tout le monde et donc
moi compris nous avons très peu parlé
des problèmes de cette catégorie
c'est une catégorie très nombreuses
puisque comme vous savez elle est
maintenant plus nombreuses que la
catégorie des ouvriers en france et
c'est une catégorie qui était
essentielle à notre activité économique
notre vie nationale en poupe sorte de
branches qui sont ses employés ses
cadres moyens ils ont eu le sentiment
qu'ils étaient non pas je dirais
maltraité mais ignorées par la politique
des dernières années pourquoi parce que
on a voulu resserrer les inégalités en
france etc ont donc on s'est préoccupée
à la fois des catégories défavorisées
travailleurs au voisinage du smic faible
rémunération de branches de travailleurs
manuels qu'en même temps on a réduit
l'écart au sommet en réduisant par la
fiscalité
les revenus les plus élevés et que qui
étaient au milieu il était en quelque
sorte ignoré par ces deux évolutions et
donc leurs problèmes en tant que telle
ne paraissait pas être traités comme ce
sont ceux qui paient qui perdent
emploi notre fiscalité nationale
isabelle sentiment d'être laissés pour
compte dans cette évolution
la deuxième chose qui lézardent doit
préoccuper c'est que pour des raisons de
justice sociale et aussi de limitation
de ressources certaines des prestations
qui ont été créés par exemple supplément
familial pour les familles nombreuses ou
les régime d'accession à la propriété
pour la construction ont fait l'objet
d'un plafonnement et ce plafonnement de
ressources laissait une partie de ces
catégories en dehors alors ils se sont
dit voilà d'une part nous bénéficions
pas de ce qui est fait pour les
catégories les plus les moins favorisés
et d'autre part on met des plafonds qui
font que même les avantages de notre
catégorie une bonne partie d'entre nous
ne peut pas en bénéficier alors ma
réponse est double d'abord dans notre
fiscalité il faut que cette catégorie
soit traiter avec justice
vous savez que les tranches du barème de
l'impôt et élargi en 1980 pour 1981 dans
la proportion de la hausse des prix est
à mon avis il faut que ceux-ci soient
faites encore l'année prochaine
il ne faut pas qu'il y ait du fait de la
hausse des prix une aggravation de la
fiscalité de cette catégorie moyen est
ce c'est donc un engagement que je
prends au cas où je serais élu deuxième
engagement c'est de regarder cette
question des plafonds de ressources car
il n'est pas normal en effet que
certaines actions qui ont été prévus
pour la catégorie moyenne notamment
l'accession à la propriété de son
logement et cartes par le jeu de ces
plafonds de ressources des catégories
importantes de ces de ses avantages et
donc il faut réexaminer ces plafonds de
façon à ce que ces systèmes puissent
bénéficier plus largement à l'ensemble
des employés les cadres moyens
un chiffre pour la construction
individuelle pas je voudrais citer dans
cette émission ensemble en quelques
chiffres en espérant n'ont pas trop je
crois qu'on a droit à trois premiership
réciter parce que c'est un titre est
très important pour moi dans la
psychologie profonde française de savoir
qu'à l'heure actuelle dans les
intentions de vote
il ya autant d'ouvriers qui ont
l'intention de voter pour moi que
d'ouvriers que l'intention de voter pour
monsieur marchait ou d'ouvriers que
notre action de voter pour monsieur
mitterrand
pour qu'on le sache deuxième chiffre la
construction de maisons individuelles
parce que nous étions en temps de crise
j'ai fait faire refaire le compte
pendant mon septennat on a construit en
france un million huit cent quarante
mille maisons individuelles
il n'y a qu'à regarder quand vous
promener à la sortie des villes grandes
et moyennes vous verrez ces maisons
individuelles un million huit cent
quarante mille et donc en temps de crise
on a construit environ 30% de plus que
pendant le septennat précédent et un
dernier chiffre parce que s'adresse
aussi la vie collective et quotidienne
des français
quand j'ai été élu il y avait six
millions de lignes téléphoniques en
france et il y en a à l'heure actuelle
16 millions et vous n'avez qu'à faire
une expérience simple retrouver chez
vous les vieux annuaires mais qu'à
regarder les annuaires de 1973 ou 74 les
annuaires de la dernière année et vous
verrez le développement de cette
facilité qui était une facilité pour
toutes les catégories notamment les
catégories moyennes donc nous avons
travaillé pendant sept
alors justement maintenant venons en à
la politique étrangère donc à des
questions sans chiffres il ya un thème
qui était le sujet de polémique numéro
un depuis le début de cette campagne et
qui touche aux relations est-ouest que
vous êtes le président sortant
naturellement c'est votre rôle qui est
d'abord mis en avant et au fond ce qu'on
vous reproche aux adversaires qu'aux
faut vivement et compris à ses émissions
naturellement elles sont faites pour ça
second tour reproche c'est d'avoir à
l'égard de l'union soviétique une
attitude l'argent coule à des termes
plutôt mesuré une attitude trop bien
élevé trop gentille et puis quand on
n'est plus désagréable avec nous on dit
que c'est trop nous et c'est que c'est
pas si que puisque qu'au fond on va
encore beaucoup plus loin
alors vrai d'abord sur cette question
que vous disiez ce pourquoi vos yeux
parce que j'imagine que vous considérez
c'est un faux procès pourquoi son état
non mais j'ai pas du tout l'intention de
répondre à cette question sous cette
forme là j'ai l'intention de vous
répondre ce que je fais ce que j'ai fait
ce que je ferai concernant les relations
est-ouest
je ne viens pas ici monsieur duhamel en
posture accusés
je n'accuse personne je n'ai pas
l'intention non plus que sur des sujets
aussi graves on s'imagine qu'on va me
placer en plus on peut sur d'accuser il
circule actuellement dans paris
paraît-il une espèce de petite brochure
éditée d'ailleurs à grands frais
et qui prétend que le président de la
république est un agent des soviets acte
et on l'envoie d'ailleurs avec des pains
sont deux postes que c'est plus discret
naturellement un certain nombre de
citoyens alors ainsi regarder le loot
rage à l'intelligence des français que
pendant deux mois vous ayez une campagne
ou à la fois c'est un monarque absolu
agents des soviets bon peut-on dire
peut-on vraiment dire à l'intelligence
des français des choses plus haute et
plus basse est d'ailleurs cette brochure
puisque vous êtes journal et son pesant
renseigner je voudrais bien savoir qui
la paix car lorsque loi son luxe et sa
dépense
je voudrais savoir qu'il appelle ne
savais pas je ne referai pas
personnellement à le savoir
alors il ya des questions de forme
la négation de fond sur les questions de
forme hélas les arguments qui entendu ou
qu'on m'a rapporté comme développer dans
les émissions de télévision sont
malheureusement inexactes
par exemple on a dit un certain moment
propos de l'afghanistan a été dit dans
une émission telle que la vôtre que
l'invasion de l'afghanistan avaient
suivi mon voyage officiel en inde
je vous rappelle que l'invasion de
l'afghanistan et du 27 décembre et qu'on
voyage officiel en inde et du 25 janvier
on a dit qu'il y avait eu des réactions
d'une extrême rapidité sauve les miennes
vas-y l'invasion l'afghanistan je vous
rappelle que la mesure l'afghanistan a
eu lieu le 27 décembre que le 28
décembre il ya une déclaration des
affaires étrangères françaises que le 30
décembre
il ya eu une réunion à londres des
principales puissances occidentales que
le 2 janvier j'ai écrit une lettre que
la presse a publié aux principaux
dirigeants des partis politiques
notamment monsieur marchait monsieur
mitterrand qui n'avait pas jusque-là
réagi pour leur dire étant donné la
gravité de la situation
je le rough mettait à leur disposition
le ministère des affaires étrangères
français et s'ils le souhaitaient moi
même de façon à ce qu'ils aient une
pleine connaissance de cette situation
draps c'était la première
hâtives c'était la mienne et je ne vous
donnerai pas lecture je voudrais pas
lecture que j'ai ici
des déclarations qui ont été faites
ensuite sur le même sujet ou la première
déclaration qui a été faite sur
l'afghanistan comparaît pour la
condamner l'entrée des forces viticole
afghanistan aux actions décidées par la
france en afrique et on disait nous
condamnons de la même manière
l'entrée des troupes soviétiques en
afghanistan et les actions de la france
en afrique voilà en effet un beau
sentiment national j'en prends
maintenant varsovie at on rappelé
qu'avant varsovie il avait eu un sommet
franco-allemand cas ce sommet
franco-allemand nous avons établi un
document comme que nous nous sommes mis
d'accord le chancelier schmitt et moi
pour que si nous rencontrions monsieur
brejnev et je vous rappelle que j'ai
rencontré monsieur bresnay fin mars aux
vies c'est à dire qu'il a fait la moitié
du chemin et que le chancelier ce mythe
est allé pour des raisons d'ailleurs que
c'est pas naturellement à critiquer à
moscou lorsque nous avons rencontré
monsieur bré snep l'un et l'autre nous
lui avons nous sommes appuyés sur le
texte de la déclaration franco-allemande
et bien sûr douleur a fait cette
déclaration de même que voilà d'ailleurs
la lettre que j'ai écrite le 2 janvier à
propos des événements d'afghanistan
cette déclaration franco allemande dit
ceci les deux pays jugent que
l'intervention militaire soviétique en
afghanistan est inacceptable et créer de
graves dangers pour la stabilité de la
région et pour la paix il estime
indispensable qu'elle y soit mis fin
sans délai c'est le seul moyen de
restaurer à une situation conforme au
droit du peuple afghan et aux exigences
de la paix internationale et un autre
paragraphe qui est le suivant il déclare
c'est à dire le chancelier schmitt et
moi que la détente ne résisterait pas un
nouveau choc du même entre dans ce cas
la france et la république fédérale
d'allemagne prendrait en liaison avec
leurs alliés les mesures qui
s'imposeraient dans cette circonstance
pour garantir leur sécurité et défendre
la stabilité internationale pouvait-on
dire quelque chose de plus et les
l'homme d'état zones publiques qui ont
commenté le voyage à varsovie et qui le
critiquent aujourd'hui j'aurais voulu
faire entendre leurs déclarations car il
y eu des déclarations à la radio on
pourrait donc entendre les voix et pas
seulement lire les écrits ils ont dit si
c'est pour tenir à monsieur bré ce bf le
langage de la fermeté
il faut aller avoir fait or je suis allé
à varsovie dire ce qui figurait dans la
déclaration franco allemand
et donc voilà pour la force au candidat
ce dont vous parlez c'est giscard
d'estaing est ce que vous ne regrettez
pas a posteriori par exemple avant de
vous êtes rendus à varsovie devoir
expliquer aux français pour que vous y
alliez et après avoir été varsovie
d'avoir expliquer aux français ce que
vous y aviez dit je crois pas je crois
qu'il faut admettre que dans les
relations internationales dans les
situations de grande difficulté de
grande crise il ya des choses qu'il faut
dire et il ya des choses pour lesquelles
on doit vous faire confiance je j'ai
fait vérifier que le compte rendu de
l'entretien de varsovie a été déposée
par mes soins aux archives nationales et
donc on connaîtra le détail cette
conversation de varsovie et à ce moment
là bien des jugements apparaîtront à la
fois léger et les représentant cédant 30
ans hec derrière plutôt aussi le ciel me
rappellait c'est à dire que
vous allez dire enfin ça monsieur
brejnev un certain nombre de propos très
très dur chacun peut contre la position
de l'écouter sur des sujets pareil des
sujets dont dépendent les relations
internationales et dans une large mesure
la paix et la guerre vous comprendrez
qu'on ne tiennent pas des propos
imprudents et il ya des choses que des
journalistes peuvent dire les
commentateurs peuvent dire il est des
choses que des hommes des caches doivent
dans certaines circonstances dû garder
pour eux je suis allé et je les ai
indiqué dire à mes cheveux relief que la
détente ne résisterait pas un phoque du
même nom sur le fond alors sur le fond
oui alors sur le fond par exemple la
france et les autres pays européens et
les états unis ont protesté après
l'entrée des troupes soviétiques en
afghanistan
on a protesté puis les troupes
soviétiques sont toujours en afghanistan
autrement dit dans un cas comme ça
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
justement posé une question utile
d'abord également un autre candidat qui
parlait peut-être chez vous et qui a
employé les expressions que j'ai dû
relever parce qu fut tout à fait pour la
critique vous voyez mais par contre
comme président de la république leur
présente la france il ya donc un langage
qu'on doit pas tenir vis-à-vis du
président de la république même si la
muse parce que il n'amuse pas uniquement
à ses dépens il amuse également aux
dépens de la réputation de la france à
l'extérieur il ya une presse
internationale il ya des gens qui
commentent ce que nous disons et c'est
pourquoi j'ai relevé les termes mais on
n'a pas indiqué au cours de cette
semaine entretien qu'au sommet de venise
il y à une déclaration unanime des
participants et que cette déclaration
était une cour d'assises condamnations
très fermes de l'intervention soviétique
en afghanistan alors l'action est une
action qui est conduite au premier rang
par les pays islamiques eux mêmes dont
vous savez nous appuyons l'action et
avec lesquels nous concerne pas car ces
deux qui sont au premier rang dans cette
situation et c'est donc avec eux qu'il
faut créer les conditions d'un retrait
des forces soviétiques d'afghanistan
le choix vous parler maintenant de la
pologne oui mais
on y arriver oui justement si par
hypothèse est ce qui n'est pas tout à
fait exclue il y avait des affrontements
en pologne et peut-être même un
soulèvement populaire pour rejeter
l'équipe dirigeante actuelle est
peut-être pour s'écarter dieu du régime
en dehors de larmes de crocodile et de
regret est probablement sincère qu'est
ce que nous pourrions faire
l'occident la france qu'est ce que vous
pourriez oui il faudrait préciser il
faudra préciser que c'est dans
l'hypothèse où ce serait un affront d
affrontement interne c'est à dire sur le
mans contre le gouvernement polonais a
pas besoin d'intervention soviétique et
là nous adressons candidats au président
oui il faut voir la situation actuelle
de la pologne et qui est une situation
où il ya un x ou y à la fois des aspects
politiques et où il ya des aspects
économiques et sociaux
vous savez que la situation interne de
la pologne est à l'heure actuelle
extrêmement critique et il faut bien
voir que la pologne ce n'est pas un
petit pays où certains pays en
développement je le dis sans sens
péjoratif c'est un pays qui ressemble à
ce que nous sommes nous mêmes c'est un
pays de 35 millions d'habitants et c'est
un pays dont le niveau de vie et par
exemple double du niveau de vie du
brésil ce n'est pas du tout à des pays
en développement que nous aidons dans le
tiers-monde
or à l'heure actuelle la pologne et dans
la plus grande difficulté économique et
social y compris pour son
approvisionnement quotidien
notre attitude sera d'aider la pologne
et je voudrais pas qu'on découvre l'est
de la pologne à l'occasion de la
campagne électorale la france à aider la
pologne dès 1980 pour des montants
considérables
nous sommes avec les allemands fédéraux
les deux pays qui est dont la pologne
notre aide à la pologne qui était une
aide sous forme de crédits tous est un
peu complexe a représenté 4 milliards de
francs en 1981 nôtres est donc 1980
représentera un montant du même nom nous
avons répondu à toutes les demandes des
aides alimentaires des autorités
polonaises desquelles ont été présentés
et pour le montant de leur donnant c'est
à dire une première fois mois de
descendre une deuxième fois au conseil
européen où nous avons décidé de donner
une réponse immédiate aux demandes
polonaises
je reçois demain matin le vice premier
ministre polonais vous avez du salut
être annoncées je crois dans
et qui est le négociateur des accords de
gdansk et pourquoi c'est parce que la
france est actuellement le chef de file
des pays qui organisent l'aide à la
pologne
nous allons continuer à aider la pologne
bien entendu dans un esprit de
fraternité
compte tenu des liens d'amour avec la
pologne vous savez que pendant tout mon
septennat je me suis efforcé de
développer ses liens contenus aussi de
l'importance de la tradition polonaise
en france puisque c'est un des groupes
qui est associé de la façon la plus
étroite à notre vie nationale
mais alors cette aide à la pologne est
destinée à permettre aux polonais de
réorganiser leurs économies de redresser
leur économie est bien entendu sans
intervention extérieure est également
sans violence intérieure qui reviendrait
sur les acquis du peuple polonais nos
protestations de la france ne tarderai
pas s'il y avait une gelée dit tout à
l'heure dans le thème son plan des
principes vous pensez qu'il faut qu'on
peut faire preuve de fermeté et qu'il
faut dialoguer vous savez où vous
l'entendez pendant cette campagne
électorale que pour beaucoup le dialogue
c'est une preuve de pacifisme et
peut-être même de faiblesse est ce qu'il
ya une autre solution mais naturellement
il n'y en a pas deux autres il faut se
rappeler l'histoire de france ils vont
de france récente et il ne faut pas que
l'histoire de france soit absente du
débat national
la france a perdu deux guerres au cours
du dernier siècle
elle a perdu la garde 70 celle a perdu
la guerre de 39 40
et elle a été associée heureusement à la
victoire de 44 45
et elle a gagné la guerre de 14 18 elle
a perdu deux guerres et ses girls ont
dévasté l'ont affaiblie ont mis fin
pendant de longues périodes son
influence à son rayonnement
international et quand on circule dans
certaines de nos de nos régions du nord
et de l'est on voit encore que le retard
a été pris à l'occasion séguin s'est
guère comment la france et l antre elle
y est entré sans les avoir préparés
militairement et en se livrant à une
refus ou à une impréparation dans son
dialogue ou dans sa discussion avec ses
adversaires potentiels
vous savez que la guerre de soixante dix
n'avaient pas été préparées
militairement qui a pas eu de dialogue
que la france y est entré kelly a perdu
deux des provinces qui lui sont les plus
chers et vous savez qu'elle est entrée
dans la guerre de 1939 1940 sans
préparation militaire poivey proto qu'à
un degré d'impréparation qui est
historiquement coupable qu'est-ce que
j'ai fait mon corps de sept ans d'abord
avec les cartes de notre armée parce
qu'il ya les matériels ont retour des
matériels mais les hommes c'est à dire
les officiers les sous-officiers de
notre armée en même temps les jeunes les
zones appelées les jeunes engagés les
deux nous avons fait de la france la
troisième puissance militaire du monde
et je le redis parce que les gens le
savent pas nous l'avons fait ça l'effort
annuel
nous sommes à l'heure actuelle si la
france employait toutes ses armes
elle est plus forte que tout autre pays
à l'exclusion tête à vie d'amérique et
de l'union soviétique
donc nous sommes en position de force et
par contre j'ai pas voulu refaire les
erreurs historiques du passé c'est à
dire ne pas conduire un dialogue avec
les autres puissances car on doit
connaître les intentions des autres
puissances et elles doivent connaître
les nôtres par exemple dans l'attitude
de l'union soviétique à l'heure actuelle
je suis convaincu que ce qui lui a été
dit par le chancelier imité par moi même
ce qui lui a été dit directement est
certainement un élément qui pèse dans
cette décision
jusqu'à quand jusqu'à quel point
pèsera-t-il je ne peux pas le dire mais
c'est certainement un élément important
donc là la règle pour un pays comme la
france c'est la sécurité un très haut
niveau et c'est le dialogue avec les
puissances responsable de la paix la
sécurité dans le monde et si je suis élu
je continuerai qu'on ne s'attende pas à
l'occasion de cette campagne électorale
que je modifie mon attitude turin de ces
deux prises accepter toutes les
critiques apparemment la salle qui omet
hors de vous c'est la politique non pas
de moi je peux demain mais je veux dire
ça touche sa touche véritablement la
sécurité l'essentiel de la vie française
je pourrais dire des choses extrêmement
sévère quand je l'entends reproché au
président de la république d'avoir
poursuivi un dialogue pour la paix et
quand je pense aux attitudes qui ont été
prises depuis 15 ans
en ce qui concerne notre défense
nationale et les moyens de cette défense
nationale jeudi là qu'un haut degré
d'irresponsabilité
alors je ne vais pas plus loin mais j'ai
exprimée fermement ces taupes il ya un
reproche à sion politique étrangère qui
est adressé à l'occasion d'un contact
notamment évidemment étudié celui de
vous entendre trop bien avec tout le
monde on dit ici au fond on s'entend
bien avec les soviétiques
on s'entend bien avec les américains
c'est sans doute qu'on me pèse pas assez
oui on me reproche par contre ne pas
s'entendre très bien avec telle ou telle
personne j'ai vu qu'on me reprochait
notamment tendre très bien avec le
colonel kadhafi j'accepte cette critique
par contre en effet la france est un
pays qui doit conduire un effort de
recherche de relations pacifiques dans
le monde et donc nous conduisons un
effort de relations pacifiques
est-ce que c'est facile de passer du
personnage de candidats d'un personnage
de président de la république qu'est ce
que c'est quel sens par exemple
lorsqu'on vous parle de politique
étrangère naturellement nous avons le
président d'un public en face de nous
mais pour vous quel type d'exercice
qu'est ce que ça représente parce que
c'est vous considérez que c'est une
sorte de handicap ours est un atout pour
cette campagne
non je crois que c'est un handicap mais
que c'est un handicap qu'il faut assumer
complètement voilée parce que quelle est
la vérité dans nos l'handicap crois que
les français ont peint ces mots en une
attitude de compréhension vis à vis du
président de la république en exercice
quel qu'il soit mais naturellement ils
lui imputent les difficultés de l'époque
comme l'époque qu'une période de crise
le fait d'avoir été à la tête de l'état
pendant une période de crise était
handicapé c'est un handicap que
j'entends bien sûr monde une dernière
question politique internationale
dans les critiques qui peuvent être
exprimés il ya des critiques de fond on
en est maintenant pour épier aussi des
critiques de forme ou de sensibilité
il ya une chose qui avait choqué
beaucoup de gens et ça s'était très bien
senti c'était lorsque au cours de votre
fameuse tournée au moyen-orient vous
aviez regardé israël à travers des
jumelles depuis le territoire de la
jordanie aujourd'hui savoir comment vous
réagissez quand vous entendez ce genre
de fêter parce que c'est vrai que là on
s'aperçoit très bien que un geste prend
valeur de symbole quelques pas plus
important que ce que vous avez raison de
dire sur le fond j'ai au contraire
refuser que ce geste est une valeur de
symbole vous pouvez vous renseigner
auprès de ceux qui accompagnaient mon
expédition
je suis parti d'amman pour aller voir le
jour teint et nous sommes posés en
hélicoptère sur une hauteur dont on
voyait en effet en face le territoire
d'israël et 7è pts comme c'est une
frontière militaire il y avait des
installations militaires
j'ai dit que je n'acceptais pas comme
eux photographie dans un emplacement de
cette nature il y avait les télévisions
les photographes j'ai dit je descendrai
pas d'hélicoptère car je ne veux pas
qu'il y est une image représentant le
président la pluie françaises regardent
en israël avec une paire de jumelles et
il n'y a jamais eu cette image
par contre c'était en jordanie j'ai
parcouru ce pays
je peux vous dire par contre quand j'en
ai retiré le sentiment que la frontière
jordan hall israélienne et tapez pouvait
être une frontière pacifique c'est à
dire qu'il n'y avait pas je n'ai pas
ressenti heureusement une tension en vue
de l'affrontement des deux côtés de
cette frontière sud interrompre les
monsieur giscard d'estaing jeu on vient
de passer un mot important ce problème
d'information il ya eu un attentat
contre le président américain reagan il
n'a pas été blessé mais son porte parole
a été ainsi que deux agents de la
sécurité n'en sait pas davantage
oui berry jovan me transmettre ce
message je voulais vous
le dire pour vous l'avenir donc premier
geste en rentrant à l'elysée sera bien
entendu de lui envoyer un message de
sympathie et le veut malheureusement
nous vivons dans un monde de violence
la france est peut-être plus exemptés
que d'autres de cette situation de
violence devons faire tous les efforts
pour la maintenir dans cet état donc les
chefs d'état doivent être protégés n'ont
donc on veut pouvoir plus d'impôts en
tout cas les candidats n'ont eu une ou
deux dernières questions parce que le
temps a passé oui alors celle que je
voudrais vous poser en ce qui me
concerne si vous êtes réélu comment est
ce que vous ferez pour échapper à ce
sortilège qui donne le sentiment que
l'issue de toute élection démocratique
en france on a toujours l'impression que
c'est la moitié de la france qui
l'emportent sur l'autre moitié dans
toute élection démocratique dans le
monde se fait à 50 50 par ce pour une
raison simple c'est que comme les
candidats veulent être élus il vise
toujours vers le centre vers l'électorat
du centre est donc finalement ils
obtiennent toujours un résultat qui est
voisin de saint jean tout dépend de
l'attitude qu'ils prennent au lendemain
d'élections ils peuvent prendre une
attitude écrasement de l'adversaire où
ils peuvent prendre une attitude de
conduite démocratique des affaires du
pays si je suis élu je prendrais
l'attitude de la conduite des montres
démocratique des affaires de la france
d'abord je ne dissoudrai par l'assemblée
parce que j'estime qu'il serait il
légitime de dissoudre l'assemblée
étant donné qu'elle a été élue de la
façon la plus démocratique en 1978 après
un très large débat national pourquoi la
dissout et donc ce sera elle qui aura à
se prononcer sur les principaux projets
du gouvernement et d'autre part comme je
les dis je chercherai une approche non
partisane sur trois sujets essentiels la
défense la politique étrangère l'emploi
les effets de serre oui les français
d'un instant de crise semble dire à tous
les candidats y compris à vous donnez
nous un idéal donnez-nous une ambition
de nous le goût de vivre et d'espérer et
on leur répond par des programmes
importants des plans sur l'emploi des
programmes économiques certes encore une
fois très important mais où est le
souffle ou et l'imagination où est
l'espoir pour eux alors est ce que vous
vous en sentez capable si vous êtes élu
et pourquoi maintenant
plus qu'avant est-ce que vous pouvez le
voir le show capcom n'ait pas assisté à
ma réunion de samedi à la porte de
pantin très suivie et si vous avez suivi
à la télé vous avez toujours la réaction
de la jeunesse française parce que les
gens qui disent quittait le langage que
vous tenez
excusez moi je vous le dire ils
appartiennent au milieu politique
c'est-à-dire qu'ils disent entre eux
alors qu'ils sont jugés par le
scepticisme faut bien le dire ils disent
bay faudrait donner un grand souffle un
grand idéal qu'est ce que ça veut dire
un gros sous sont idéales pour être élu
c'est pas du tout mon idée c'est que je
crois qu'il faut au contraire suscité en
france des forces qui x 9 et notamment
la force de la jeunesse et je suis sûr
qu'il ya en france une grande réserve
d'enthousiasmé de volonté dans la
jeunesse française et c'est pourquoi si
je suis élu au sens le plus simple du
terme
je dédie raymond septaine à nouveau à la
jeunesse parce que c'est elle qui
apportera le souffle la nouveauté
l'ardeur dans les affaires de la france
et le rôle du président de la république
le produit dictée et son idéal à la
jeunesse mais c'est de créer les
conditions dans lesquelles la jeunesse
d'un pays peut apporter son propre
enthousiasme et son propre idéal
la jeunesse française en est et on sera
capable je ne comptait pas parmi les
sceptiques
merci à monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing devant participer avec nous à
ce cartes sur table qui est la dernière
grande émission politique
nous avons organisé à l'occasion des
élections présidentielles bonsoir
[Musique]